desde el lejano oriente ruso hasta moscú
pasando por las principales ciudades de
la región siberiana miles de rusos
salieron a las calles de hasta 142
ciudades del país para exigir la
liberación del líder opositor alexéi
navalni estas personas denuncian la
represión ejercida durante estos años
por el gobierno de vladímir putin
las leyes no se cumplen no hay libertad
de expresión no hay derechos no hay
tribunales las autoridades no quieren
escuchar a nada ni a nadie
y claro que hay represión encarcelan a
personas inocentes en nombre de
artículos descabellados por eso salí y
saldré aunque las autoridades realizaron
un despliegue previo de policías y
cortaron varias calles del centro de
moscú no se evitaron los enfrentamientos
con los manifestantes las
reivindicaciones de éstos fueron
pacíficas pero miles de ellos fueron
detenidos incluida la esposa de navalny
julian habana ya una reacción que muchos
creen desmedida y los taxistas ya no
hable de lo que estoy viendo ahora es
una reacción inadecuada la gente estaba
saliendo pacíficamente no estaban
haciendo nada ilegal
ahora hay intimidación pero como pueden
ver nadie tiene miedo ni fe ni weitz
alexéi navalni está preso desde el 17 de
enero mientras se decide sobre una
condena suspendida por malversación de
fondos que el opositor tacha de
manipulada naval ni regresó hace dos
semanas a rusia luego de recuperarse en
alemania de un envenenamiento por el
agente tóxico soviético no [__]